Our planet is amazing.
Swirling around the sun at a high speed of 107,218 km / h, the speed of Durana is considered
Great for its size - the weight of the Earth's mass
According to the calculations of 5,972,190,000,000,000,000,000,000,000 (five subtilis, nine hundred and seventy-two stencils
And ninety-one quintillion kilos).
Although the planet is always losing or gaining a mass
We estimate the amount of global dust attracted by gravity by about 40,000 tons
Where the earth acts as a giant broom - this dust acts as a remnant of the solar system, and crashes asteroids, and
Materials that did not turn into planets.
But we lose a large amount of mass due to gases (emitted from the ground)
Hydrogen is a light gas emitted to the atmosphere at an average rate
3 kg per second - equivalent to 95,000 tons per year.
But what about us?
The population reached 5 billion in 1987, now estimated at 7.6 billion people!
Do our bodies and everything we put on the surface of the planet affect a mass
Our planet?
No, because we are made up of matter that already exists on the planet.
This article is an atom - 118 different species have been identified (elements)
But there are 3 elements that make up 90% of our composition: oxygen (65%), carbon (18.5%), and hydrogen
(9.5%)
Two of them are important for life: water.
The oceans account for about 70% of the planet.
At the deepest point the marina trench is 10,994 m - if placed
Mount Everest base at the bottom of the ditch, the summit will reach 1.6 km
Underwater.
A large part of the ocean is still unknown - only 5% of it may be detected.
We may be able, with greater knowledge, to understand how the Dead Sea Octopus (Granilidon Boriopasivalica)
Eggs for the longest recorded period (pregnancy).
This requires the mother to take more than 160 eggs to plant in Monterey Bay
And protect them for 53 months without eating throughout this period, and still do not know how
Survived throughout this period.
Although it is clear that there are animals with distinctive characteristics such as cats and dogs,
But many scholars have rejected this idea.
There are now approved surveys to measure the distinctive chimpanzees
Resulting from natural selection.
All this happens on the earth's crust, which amounts to only 1% of
The size of the land.
There are many forms of life on Earth.